joining us now with reaction retired CIA
senior intelligence officer now Fox News
contributor Daniel Hoffman is with us I
love what the way the president phrases
that again missiles not fired over Japan
guam's not in jeopardy the Korean
Peninsula is more safe tonight hostages
released cross the DMZ Trump pulls out
they beg plead no no no no please please
PLEASE no downside I didn't we didn't
pay any cash this time did we yeah
that's right it's quite a contrast from
what the Obama administration gave up to
get Bowe Bergdahl back some pretty five
really significantly bad terrorists but
what I would highlight about about
tomorrow's meeting and today's meeting
between secretary Pompeo and kim
yeongcheol kim yeongcheol is a four-star
general former head of military
intelligence deep background in nuclear
negotiations absolutely reflects Kim
jong-un the seriousness with which Kim
jong-un is approaching what looks like a
summit in Singapore on 12 June now kim
kim youngchul is an unsavory character
he's been sanctioned for targeting Sony
Pictures with that cyber attack and
being responsible for killing 46 South
Korean sailors back in 2010 but this is
the hand were dealt with and it's part
of the challenge of dealing with the
Hermit Kingdom you know these are the
kind of negotiations that will have to
take place with some unsavory characters
I I love the fact that all of these kind
of big developments have happened the
president has given up nothing and I
think the the fact that the media
doesn't understand and the left doesn't
understand this is the art of the deal
this is how you negotiate maybe it
happens on the 12th maybe it doesn't
maybe it takes one meeting two meetings
three meetings maybe more you know what
we're gonna try our best this is worth
worth it for the couple not only the
country but for the world and so much
progress that again I I think Kristin
was right we didn't anticipate six
months ago right I think North Korea
tried to practice the art of diplomatic
brinksmanship and they failed when the
president walked away from the summit
and North Korea came back with a very
conciliatory absolutely not at all
bellicose message indicating that they
were really serious about wanting to
talk to us now again this is a this is
going to be an
extraordinary complex theories of
negotiations Russia is already
interfering with secretary a Minister of
Foreign Affairs Lavrov visiting
Pyongyang today and talking about
ratcheting down the sanctions which is
not helpful but again I think we're
playing our hand as well as we possibly
could I wouldn't expect any immediate
gratification for us but I do believe
that we're we've already absolutely
showing the North Koreans that that we
mean business and that the pattern that
we followed here showing some strength
to North Korea clearly has been a lot
more effective than what we've seen from
the past two decades and the president I
think rightly so managing expectations
in terms of what they should expect if
it happens if it doesn't happen it's the
ball is going to be in their court and
it's going to be about denuclearization
I'm very impressed with the new
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo a
brilliant man and and obviously
following through in the president's
policies thank you